my name is ax haymeyer I am the director
of academic programs here at the
Stanford center for professional
development
so I oversee our credit bearing
portfolio I also work with Petra my
colleague who I'll introduce herself in
a second with the AI and computer
science programs so that Petra you want
to introduce yourself yes great thank
you so much Pax and also big welcome
from me uh my name is Petra parikova I'm
I'm the associate director for our
computer science and artificial
intelligence programs and courses at
scpd and I see a bunch of questions are
coming in please keep it coming we will
try to get to as many as we can
and as Pax mentioned we will be talking
to you more closely today about kind of
our artificial intelligence portfolio uh
at Stanford center for professional
development we will be focusing on two
main programs tax will be covering a
little bit more about the AI graduate
program at scpd and I will be talking a
little bit more about the AI
professional program so we will cover
more details how they work
um differences all these kind of things
but just for your information just for
you to know those are not the only
things we have within our portfolio on
the subject of AI we have some other
courses also on building an AI enabled
organization and things like that
um or Coursera machine learning
specialization or if this is something
like AI machine learning if it's subject
that you are just starting with we also
have a lot of free content available on
YouTube and we also run um
webinars quite frequently that we also
try to post on YouTube so uh we will be
talking mainly about the AI graduate
program and professional program but
just for you to know there are also some
other things you could consider you can
always find more information at Stanford
online website site
thanks Petra and we briefly wanted to
mention a new course that we are
offering it is really does not fit into
either the professional graduate program
it's a bit of an experiment for us it's
on designing robust and reliable AI
systems you should see a link in your
resources it's the third one down it
says new course just click on that if
you want more information this program
is being run by the executive director
of the Stanford center for AI safety
Anthony Corso he'll be going over these
five topics around designing robust and
reliable AI systems it's a one-week
program and there will be assignments
that go along with it but it'll
basically be a a live lecture where you
can watch a recording of the lecture in
the morning it's completely online
there'll be an opportunity to work on
the assignments with the facilitator and
then Anthony will be providing office
hours later in the day so that's the
current plan it's it's kind of a new
model for us we're really excited about
it it's obviously a very important um
and although it's a concern that's been
around for a long time it's very Timely
right now this seems to be in the news a
lot so we're excited to offer it we'd
love to see you there we encourage you
to click on that that link to find out
more about it
all right with that though I want to
dive into more uh into more detail with
with the uh the AI graduate program so
this is one of the core parts of our
portfolio so basically what the graduate
program is is we offer credit bearing
courses the same courses that are
happening on campus we also offer to
online students who do not need to be
matriculated Stanford students in order
to take the class
this the certificate so the courses are
the same course you're doing the same
work you're in the course alongside the
students uh the certificate itself that
you would earn and I'll go into a little
bit more detail about what it takes to
earn that uh
is uh is accredited by wasp so it is an
accredited certificate program and the
last thing I'll mention is just in terms
of the cost of this program it's it's a
less than say for instance pursuing a
master's degree it still is an expensive
program it is full tuition you're paying
full tuition at Stanford this last year
Academic Year 2223 the cost of the full
program was between 18 000 and 22 000 in
US Dollars it'll probably be a little
bit more expensive this coming year as
tuition Stanford raises his tuition uh
so it is it is an intensive uh program
it's it's four courses graduate level
courses
so let me give you a little bit more
detail on what those courses are so what
you're seeing now is kind of a list of
the full courses that are part of that
AI graduate certificate and you'll see
that in order to earn the certificate
you have to take at least one of the
required core courses
and at least three uh two to three of
the electives if you did both the
required courses you only need to do two
electives so it's four courses in total
outside of the core course you have a
lot of freedom to choose what you want
to take in order to earn that
certificate I want to also emphasize
that when we talk about the AI graduate
program you do not need to pursue the
certificate you can also take a single
course or just two courses if you're
interested and while what I have here
are all the courses that are part of the
AI certificate program there are a lot
of other courses that are on topics
related to or even about AI that are not
part of that certificate program
you do not need to restrict yourself to
these programs you really can take any
of those courses that you're qualified
for and that you're admitted into
um and through Stanford online so uh
some of the courses for instance that
are not listed here there are a few
around robotics that that we also offer
that are not listed here that might be
of interest there's some statistics
courses uh like statistical learning
which is one of the you know
foundational uh foundational ideas of of
machine learning there's some
prerequisite type courses that you could
also take so you don't need to restrict
yourself into it uh into this the course
is in the certificate program and I'll
go into this a little bit more detail in
a second but I also want to emphasize
that this is
unlike say a master's degree or a
bachelor's degree you don't it doesn't
start in Fall quarter and follow you
know a clear path you can start any
quarter where a course you want to take
is offered and assuming you're you're
admitted into that course
and you do not need to be continuously
enrolled so for instance if you want to
do this summer right now what's open for
enrollment some of course on machine
learning in the course on artificial
intelligence principles and techniques
you could apply if you got in you could
take one of those courses this summer
you could then take fall quarter and
winter quarter off and take a quarter in
the next spring all that's required is
that you finish if you're if you're
pursuing the certificate all that's
required is that you take all four
courses within three years
so uh it's really a unique program I
wanted to emphasize those things because
it it really is designed for working
professionals I mean the individual
courses are are very intense and I'll go
over that in a second uh in terms of the
the work requirement I mean they're
somewhere between 15 to 30 hours a week
of work
um but in terms of when you start and
how you pursue it there's a lot of
flexibility there so if you're working
you know most of our students are
working full-time so maybe your summers
are lighter you take a course in the
summer but fall is going to just be too
busy so you don't have to take a course
in the fall but maybe then in winter
quarter you know things lighten up and
you can take another course so there's a
lot of flexibility about how you pursue
that that the certificate and again I
want to emphasize you don't need to
pursue the certificate you can just take
individual courses
um
all right uh so let me go in a little
bit more detail about what these courses
actually uh look like and how we do it
so again these are the actual classes
that are happening on Stanford's class
campus what we do is we control a couple
rooms on campus with camera systems and
you know microphone systems built in we
staff those lecture classes we record
the lectures WE Post those lectures uh
online and in the uh and and allow you
to then watch the lectures at your
convenience
you can also live stream the lectures
some of the lectures will have two-way
communication most don't so you're
really just watching the lecture and
then most of the other things that are
typical and of course are already being
handled online so there will be you know
a discussion board for instance the uh
some of the office hours will be held
online likely over something like zoom
and so you'll be able to then submit
your assignments online exams are a
little bit different you'll still have
to take exams in person but we have a
monitor process that's set up to help
you do that you'd work with either
someone at your work to deliver that
exam and person or you would go to a
testing center in order to take the
exams if there are exams so it's really
it is the same course you're taking it
alongside Stanford students in some of
the project-based courses students
pursue the projects uh with uh you know
on campus students so it's it's a you
know again it's there's nothing separate
it's the same course as the appeal of it
to a lot of of uh a lot of our students
um you do need so again
you're not admitted into the certificate
program when you apply and I'll go over
what's involved in that application
towards the end of this when you apply
you're admitted on a course by course
basis so it's not like you're admitted
into the program and then you you you
know you have however long to finish it
you are admitted on a course by course
basis and so in order to keep taking
classes you need to earn at least a b or
better to keep taking those classes if
they're computer science classes there
can be slightly different requirements
for different departments but if you're
taking AI classes the majority are on
the computer science department
you are again earning a Stanford
transcript so it is you you it's
Stanford transcript with Stanford
credits and if you were to be admitted
into a master's program at Stanford you
could transfer up to 18 of those units
towards the master's degree
so it is again you're earning Stanford
Credit you're earning a Stanford
transcript you know the key Point here
is they are the same courses uh that you
that the on-campus students are taking
it's the same course you're alongside it
I'm going to pause here to see if there
are some questions uh I see there's some
about the prerequisites so I'll get into
those
um
and then I I see there are some
questions about coming on campus so
strictly speaking these are online only
uh programs
there can be opportunities to come onto
campus if you're local these will
require instructor permission they would
sometimes require our permission as well
uh a typical example would be something
like um
if you want to take the exam in person
or if you want to come to the office
hours in person usually you can't come
to the lectures in person
um and you should be expect to be able
to take these programs fully online and
I just say that because we just came off
a year where campus was completely
locked down due to covet and so no one
who was taking these programs could come
on campus but typical in a typical year
when there isn't a global pandemic there
is some opportunity for you to to come
on campus for some parts of the program
but the expectation should still be that
you're completing the majority of it or
all of it online
um so you know you're not you can't take
a seat of a you know an on-campus
student from from the lecture hall
basically that's a great question
uh so I saw that there are some
questions about you know what you know
who who who uh who is this for so these
are really these are all graduate level
computer science classes for the most
part some of them might be in other
departments but they're graduate level
engineering class uh class classes so
they the expectation is that you are a
student with a strong stem background uh
and I'll go into prerequisite in a
second but you do need at least a
bachelor's degree and you need in order
to get into the Cs classes you need a
minimum of a 3.0 GPA
um as an on your undergraduate degree uh
and you know again these are a lot of
these are very foundational classes so
something like machine learning there's
a lot of proof you know writing proofs
mathematical proof so there is an
expectation of mathematical maturity
um and as I said these are classes that
take 15 and they can take anywhere I
think on average students report
spending 15 to 20 hours a week on them
so they are like part-time jobs they're
intense classes is and some students
spend a lot more time especially if it's
a course where for instance you know
linear algebra is I'll just jump ahead
to the next slide where we talk a little
bit more about the specific
prerequisites but you know linear
algebra is a very obviously very common
uh prerequisite for almost all of these
uh all of these AI classes if you
haven't taken linear algebra in three or
four or five years you might find that
you have to do a lot of catch up while
you're taking while you're taking the
class so that can add some time to it
they're they're intensive classes
they're again the same classes that
graduate students at Stanford are taking
let me pause here and just take a look
again at the some of the questions
um
uh
and what's I see some good questions
um
so I will say that uh you know these are
some really great questions about what
you know what the the the the the topics
of some of these courses are
um
what I will say is just uh and I see
some good questions so let me just
address a couple of these I see a good
question about can we take the courses
out of turn yeah uh yes and no so yes
you can take the courses in any order
that you would like except that some
courses are prerequisites to other
courses right so for instance uh I think
cs229 is which is machine learning is a
prerequisite for some of the other
courses so obviously you can't take
those other courses before you've taken
the prerequisite so you do need to be
sort of wary of of how these courses are
related to each other and that's listed
usually on the course uh on the course
website if you go to a course you can
see what its prerequisites are so you do
need to make sure you're fulfilling the
prerequisites in order to be able to
take a course but after that there's no
particular order that you need to take
them in and again you don't need to take
you don't need to pursue the certificate
you can
um just take an individual course and
that relates to this other um
uh a couple other interesting questions
is is uh what's the difference between a
graduate certificate and a master's
degree I see that's being answered but
I'll just address that briefly here
so the difference of course is the total
number of units that are required um you
know a the most of our graduate
certificates you can think of as
um modeled on the depth areas that are
part of the computer science master's
degree so the AI certificate program
generally speaking does not it's not
perfect but generally speaking lines up
with Stanford's computer science
master's degree artificial intelligence
depth area right so it's really like a
targeted pursuit of a subset of the
total master's degree right it's the
same right you would take the same
courses if you're pursuing the Master's
Degree as if you're pursuing the
certificate but you're just taking a
smaller slice of those courses and so it
allows Learners who don't need a
master's degree and a lot of our
Learners already have especially in AI
already have master's degrees or already
have a PhD but maybe they earned it five
or ten years ago or they earned it at a
at a university that didn't have a
specialization in AI or they weren't
ready to do the coursework in AI at that
time and now they do feel ready and so
they're plugging a sort of Gap in their
knowledge that's one one good example of
a typical student someone who's you know
I I have a master's degree in computer
science already I didn't do AI so I just
need to take a few classes to really get
up to speed on it that's a great example
and where you don't want to pursue a
whole another master's degree but you
need to plug some some gaps the other uh
other kind of students that often pursue
this are ones who only have a bachelor's
degree and are interested in potentially
going on to get a master's degree and
maybe they're interested in trying to
get into the Stanford Masters program so
they take these courses to one see if if
they're ready for graduate level
coursework and two in the event that you
are admitted into the into the Stanford
Masters program then you've already
earned up to 18 units that you can
transfer towards that master's degree
and you're farther along in the program
at that point
um I'll address one other thing is um
um is is that there's a question about
uh how many students are are registered
when the graduate program started so uh
and that's a great question I probably
should have said that beginning so you
know Petra and I are both part of the
Stanford center for professional
development actually been around since
the 50s it was started by Frederick
Turman and I think 1954 and it started
with the part-time and online well it
wasn't online obviously at that time but
part-time master's degrees it's
obviously expanded and grown uh in the
past 70 years and so it the program's
been around for a long time this
particular graduate certificate program
it's a good question I don't actually
remember when it was launched uh but I
think it's been around for at least 10
years so it's been around and these
courses have been offered for for quite
a long period of time
um so these are great questions please
keep asking them uh let me I want to
make sure that Petra has plenty of time
to talk about the professional programs
but I wanted to go into a a little bit
more um information about the the
courses themselves uh
so again these are these are based on
the graduate course and so if you want
to find out information about a
particular course you're going to want
it's going to be based on the syllabus
of the actual courses it's being offered
and many of these courses are offered by
different faculty in different quarters
so what I'd recommend doing is if you go
to Stanford online you look at our our
course pages will have a description of
the course there's often also a link out
to the the course website and many of
these courses have their own websites
that are maintained you may not see the
most up-to-date syllabus because uh you
know but you'll probably see the
syllabus from the last offering when you
go into that syllabus you're going to
you're going to see in detail uh usually
what was involved in that class what the
assignments were like uh you know what
the readings were what the projects were
you might even see examples of past
projects I really encourage if you're
thinking about it do a little bit of
research and to look into those course
syllabi because you can get a lot of
information there about what's involved
in those classes and that information
will always be more up to date than
anything we could provide on our website
because those are generally being
updated every time it's being offered by
by The Faculty so that's a really great
resource and place to kind of figure out
more because again these will change
based on who's teaching it and based on
the quarter inch they changed a little
bit every year because especially in
this field as you know things are
changing really fast
when I first started working here one of
my favorite and this has now happened
many times is remember watching a
lecture from one of the courses you know
on the the second week and they were
talking about unsolved problems or
problems that hadn't been solved and
then like in week eight they came back
and were like oh that's been solved
right so these things do change really
quickly and they've been especially
changing quickly in the last five or six
years and perhaps that change of pace
pace of change will maintain itself so
these are constantly updated so that's
why I'd recommend to go to learn a
little bit more about these programs I
do want to emphasize one thing here
um and it relates to what I was saying
about these being the same courses is
you know the the the unique benefit of
this program is that
you are taking the same course there's
no dumbing it down there's no changing
it significantly it is the same course
you're doing the same work
um but that does mean that there are two
essentially two audiences for these
courses there are the on-campus students
and they're the online students and
although you're getting the same course
of material right that that can create
challenges and there will always be a
little bit of a challenge as a fully
online student or even if you're a
student who's local who's primarily
online but coming safer exams that is a
challenge you can't just turn to the
student next to you in the class and ask
a question so it it really when you get
ready if you're thinking about taking
these courses think about that and think
about how you can prepare yourself
um to be an online student you're going
to have to be a little bit more
proactive right if there's an ed Forum
or something like that a discussion
forum where you can post questions
you're going to want to be active there
you're going to want to to take a look
at and um
you're going to want to take a look at
the the syllabi very early on to make
sure that you understand what the
requirements are on that first week of
classes so and all the deadlines and
you're going to have to line it up with
your work so there's just a lot that you
have to do you have to be a little bit
more proactive as an online student than
you might be as an on-campus student so
I wanted to emphasize it because these
are really hard courses and they're not
for everyone and there are some unique
challenges and opportunities in this
program
all right I I should also yeah I skipped
over this maybe I do want to emphasize
that you will have you know largely the
same support as on-campus students there
will be faculty office hours that should
be dedicated teaching assistants who are
also holding office hours uh there's
student messaging forums again a lot of
what's happening in these courses anyway
is happening online or happening through
these message forms because many of the
courses are quite large even on campus
so uh you know the natural language
processing course had 800 students I
think enrolled in it this last winter uh
so you know the difference between being
an online student and an on-campus
student is maybe not so great in an 800
person course where you know it's back
of the lecture hall or just watching the
recording online but you know again you
are part of the course you can reach out
to the Tas and the teaching team uh just
as you would if you're an on-campus
student
let me see if there are any other what
other I know a lot of questions are
coming in and these are great
um sometimes great question about I just
see one at the top is their ta assigned
for the online students there are Tas
who will hold online office hours
um in some of those courses have
specific Tas who are specifically
assigned to support the online students
some of the some of the courses don't do
that again it's very much up to the
faculty and how they want to to run it
um
it's here let me just quickly um
I I see uh you know how are these
different from something like Corsair or
mooc I mean this is you know it's the
same thing as um you know I'd say is
these are very intense courses I would
just take a look at like the syllabus
um although you'll be watching
recordings of the course you are part of
a cohort of students who are moving
through it at the same time of both
online students like yourself as well as
uh on-campus students right so there is
a much stronger social mechanism I guess
there for support and for working
through the material there are obviously
also actual people who are responding to
your questions and Grading your
assignments uh Etc so it is it is you
know it's it is a class it is just like
a if you've taken a university level
class it is a university level class
that is being offered it's just that you
uh
and you're just doing it uh you're doing
it online
um
I see some questions about access to
other things you you do um I don't want
to go into too much detail because I
want to make sure petrol I've already
like taken up too much time on this I'll
go in a little bit more detail about
some of the the resources that are
available but briefly you do have access
to all the Online Library resources you
are given a Stanford login ID and
Stanford email for the time that you're
actively enrolled in courses that allows
you to access most of the software and
resources that are available to Stanford
students if you wanted to come in person
for the libraries you'd have to pay for
Access there is a kind of visitor access
pass I think it's a hundred dollars for
for three months of of being able to get
into libraries and look at books
um let me uh jump ahead I think I have
one more slide here uh all right and
I'll just mention this before handing it
over to to Petra so in terms of
application for these for for taking
graduate courses or pursuing The
Graduate certificate you go to our
Stanford online home home page you you
will uh you you will create an account
you'll fill out an application
the application is it's not like
applying for a master's degree right you
will need a statement of purpose you'll
need to upload uh information about your
your transcripts so we can verify that
you meet the prerequisites that you can
verify what your minimum GPA is ETC
you'll add some information about your
professional experience and then you
also do need to provide some information
about your residency status here in the
US or if you're abroad you know you
there's just information on that kind of
documentation and then your application
is actually not complete until you
enroll in your first course because as I
said you're not admitted into a program
you are your application is reviewed on
a course by course basis and so you will
enroll in a course and at that point the
department will review your application
say does this student meet the
prerequisites for this program for this
course excuse me for this course and
then you'd be admitted in that course
now when you take your next course
they're going to review that application
again and make sure you're meeting the
prerequisites for that course as well
um we'll have some more either a ton of
questions and since uh since we're we're
I've already eaten up so much time I
want to pass it off to Petra and I'll
try to answer some of these questions in
the chat or save them for the end so um
but I guess I'll again to emphasize here
the application is there's no GRE or no
test scores that are required you can
apply anytime that there's a course that
you're interested in taking is offered
so if you wanted to take a course this
summer you could apply right now and
take a course this summer if you want to
take it in the fall right you could
apply in a couple months and take a
course in the fall so you can apply at
any time that of course is offered that
you want to take
all right uh and there's a little QR
code if you want to find out more so
I'll leave that here for just a second
or two and then Petra I'm going to hand
it off to you
yes of course thank you so much Pax and
it was a great introduction also as a
starting point for the AI professional
program and just to say currently I'm
seeing 130 questions that came in and we
are doing our best to address all of
them if you don't get to yours ideally
apologize but you should hopefully
received an email address along with
your kind of invitation so please don't
hesitate to follow up after the call
um so let me cover some details about
the AI professional program so the AI
professional program is basically a
series of online courses that are kind
of closely mimicking the graduate
courses so if you if Pax talked about
courses like cs221 artificial
intelligence principles and techniques I
will be talking about xcs221 artificial
intelligence principles and techniques
that is like based on the graduate class
that is taught at Stanford University
what we do though we try to make it more
manageable for professional audiences
what this means is that we are trying to
lower the time commitment so just to
kind of keep it straight we are not
trying to make it simpler so if you join
our professional class it doesn't mean
it will be easier that you know the
assignments will be much simpler none of
this we are not coming across we might
be trying to find some ways how to basic
basically lower the time commitment
so I think on average in the graduate
class you would be spending let's say 15
to 20 hours a week on the course again
an average some people spend much more
some people spend less in the AI
professional program we would be
spending 10 to 15 hours a week again an
average we see also some courses a
little bit more challenging the others
we do this basically by
segmenting and editing the videos so you
won't be getting kind of the full set of
one and a half hour long videos you will
be able to join our learning management
system and be able to kind of follow up
see videos segmented by topic and we see
this already kind of reduces the time
commitment I would say by like 10
percent
um and then also we try to find some
ways how to reduce the number of
assignments or remove the project or do
something else that would basically
lower the time commitment this generally
means that our courses don't include a
project work with the exception of XCS
to do for your natural language
understanding and we don't have any
final exams nothing like that we also
try to include usually a little bit more
hints and we also work a lot on the auto
graders so while in the original
graduate classes you might not have
access to Auto graders always some
classes do we always try to make sure
that for recording assignments you have
Auto creators so you kind of can keep
resubmitting so this all kind of brings
us to a little bit over time commitment
while still keeping the difficulty level
[Music]
um
per course yeah you can find a little
bit more information over here in terms
of which courses we are currently
offering uh these are the events uh
currently we are at seven if I'm
counting correctly starting with
artificial intelligence principles and
techniques like all the way to our
newest class deep multitask and metal
learning I saw a bunch of questions
coming in actually about a computer
vision class or some other courses
getting included in the professional
program this decision is always made
together with the faculty so I
standardly can't make any promise that
we will get this edit but standardly the
kind of the courses you are asking for
they are also on our radar and you know
we always try to do our best but we can
never make the promise right like this
is the work together with the faculty
and also the academic director
uh out of these courses
xcs224u natural language understanding
is the only course with the project work
um in terms of and we always get
questions and I think I saw a bunch of
them coming in also in the in kind of
the Q a like if you don't know where to
start like where do you start so the
first course like up here artificial
intelligence principles and techniques
it's generally the course we recommended
you starve it unless you already have
something kind of specific in mind so
is the same as in the graduate program
you can take a single course you can
take multiple courses you can take all
of them it's really up to you like we
don't require that you kind of take the
whole program you can always kind of
Join one course that you like if you do
complete three courses out of this
portfolio you will be getting AI
professional certificate so that's what
it basically means
um when I talked about the time
commitment I think it's important here
to also say that our courses are pass
fail so while in the graduate program
packs was like talking about kind of the
assignments you're getting the letter
grade in our professional program you're
getting uh kind of a professional
certificate or like certificate in the
particular course and the courses pass
fail and generally it's 70 percent to
pass the course which gives you again a
little bit more flexibility into like
you know how to succeed we obviously get
a lot of high Achievers but we also know
that some people just like can't make
the hundred percent on everything
um
we run these courses as cohort so we try
to also kind of uh kind of mimic The
Graduate course experience and having 10
weeks courses
uh so we run these as salt so-called
cohort so you will be joining a group of
students at around the same time so if
the course is starting next Monday I
believe access to 24w machine learning
with grass is starting if you join that
you will be joining like the other group
of students you won't be alone you won't
be starting on your own generally on
average we have around 120 Learners in
each particle cohort this number differs
we standard don't have less than 100 uh
sometimes we even have 200 but like 120
I think is the best guess
we have mix of written and programming
assignments and instead of kind of
teaching assistance you will be getting
support from industry experience course
facilitators those are the people who
took the original graduate class and
they will be supporting the questions
um you know you might be having about a
subject uh they also often work in the
industry directly in the field so they
can talk to you about actually the
industry applications
uh we have and I will be talking about
it more very vibrant like communities so
you're able to ask your questions live
and we always kind of encourage that for
people to be asking on slack and as I
mentioned if you complete and pastry
courses you will be getting the
professionals
the target audience is fairly similar I
would say but those are the people who
don't need the letter grade so like if
you're kind of like you just want to
learn about the subject certificate is
fine maybe you will be getting
reimbursed from your employer and you
just need to show your certificate uh
but you want the same depth and breadth
of the subject like this program is
probably right for you
prayer requisites are again fairly
similar since the level of the content
is again challenging we are trying to
make it simpler we standardly talk about
three main ones and in the applications
the those are the kind of types of
prerequisites we will be asking you
about so we expect that you're
proficient in Python we get a bunch of
people who might know I don't know you
know other languages this is totally
fine but we do require that you kind of
familiarize yourself with python before
you start
because the courses themselves they are
quite quick so there will probably not
be too much time to kind of catch up on
python if you don't know it already so
uh that's one of the product visits and
then kind of The Graduate level uh math
some people are fine with the undergrad
level math if they kind of catch up on
on some of the product visits uh using
other resources but basically College
calculus linear algebra probability
Theory this is not kind of just for fun
because we do in some courses have
written assignments and there might be
some derivations included I don't want
to scare you off but uh you know like
the math will be required for it uh on
the other hand we have some courses
where you might need a little bit of
less math but at the same time our
faculty strongly believe that this is
like very important thing to know if
you're if you want to be really good in
debugging your own software if you want
to delay not be restricted with
off-the-shelf stuff available being
creative like daily develop your own
steps Etc
uh lecture videos and I won't go to too
much detail because I think we want to
still kind of address as many questions
as possible
um so those are directly from The
Graduate course lectures it might be a
zoom video in case it happened during
pandemic we are kind of moving away
because the courses are obviously
happening now in person segmented and
edited for brevity and what is important
to note and I know that there are people
in this audience who are me maybe like
might not have the resources to pay for
these courses we try to always make the
lecture videos available also via
YouTube
so I would encourage you to check out
Stanford online uh YouTube uh portal and
find them also there like if if you
would like to kind of follow up on the
subject I also recommend people who are
interested in the classes but they can't
make the decision is this class right
for me what you are going to teach like
just do a little bit of a quick Google
search you will find lecture videos
often on YouTube uh we try to regularly
update them but the professional courses
kind of take a take a priority in that
and uh also like often the assignments
and like a lot of the course materials
is also available uh for free so I just
want to mention that because I know like
sometimes the cost might be high but you
actually get by
paying or like you know what's kind of
the value is the support from the course
facilitator you're able to ask your
questions you get a community aspect
right so there will be other 119 on
average people who will be in some sort
of a similar position you're able to
kind of network connect of course if you
want like some people don't like doing
that you also get accountability like I
Know Myself and I try to learn something
you know on my own and I'm doing that
it's sometimes hard to kind of keep the
commitment to myself if I don't have any
assignment deadline so in this case you
will probably have some assignment
deadline that kind of will keep you up
to date and at the end you will be
getting a certificate right so
especially if you want to get reimbursed
or like if you like to post it on
LinkedIn would like to find a new job
transition it might be helpful for your
kind of future career steps
won't go to Too Much details we are
using basically a similar written
assignments with a little bit more hints
we have a bunch of programming
assignments and we always develop the
auto creators so you have some sort of a
feedback so you're able to resubmit get
some sort of a feedback talk to your
course facilitator if you have any
questions
and as mentioned we do have very vibrant
like Community where you can you can
kind of use it as a forum for you to ask
questions uh it's usually the fastest
way how to get the response outside of
kind of trying to schedule 101 with your
course facilitator or if the course
facilitator is running office hours like
joining those you also have kind of like
assignment check-ins and uh different
sort of a call but I think the the spike
comedy is very helpful in getting
responses
feedback uh we won't break too much
people you know some people are happy
some people are less happy we like
people who are happy like if you find
out this course is not for you we also
have job transfer policy that is
available if you find out that you can
kind of make it at this time or maybe it
wasn't what you were looking for
and yeah I just went over it quite
quickly because I know like we want to
kind of allow enough time to at least
address some of the questions that are
coming in uh but I will pause while I'm
looking and maybe packs if you could
just give a little bit of a summary of
this like comparison between the
programs because it was a lot of
information that we want to make sure it
was somewhat understandable for you all
on the call so this is kind of a summary
slide
comparison yeah so it's a good summary
so again the uh the AI professional
program is based on the AI graduate
Court So based on the courses that are
offered at Stanford
um if you want to take the course that
is being offered at Stanford for
academic and you want to take it for
academic credit you can take it through
our AI graduate certificate through our
our
graduate programs
um
and so those are again you're taking the
same class as everyone else uh you're
taking it alongside students you're
taking it as an online student versus
the students who are taking it on campus
and matriculated students who are taking
on campus you would not be a a
matriculated student you'd be what is
called a non-degree student because
you're not pursuing a degree
um typically that it's a you know it's a
quarter system so that's usually 10
weeks summer it's a little bit shorter
it's eight weeks that's typically 10
weeks most students report spending 15
to 20 hours a week on those on a single
course
you earn again academic credit you can
take up to 18 units of academic credit
um I this was a great question that came
in and it's not here but I should add
you do need to take these courses for a
grade so these are graded courses
they're graded on the you know the the
US system a through through f
um and you do need to get a b or better
to continue taking courses in terms of
the support
there are the T you know just like if
you've taken a a course at a you know
you know it well you know an American
University you same thing with Tas with
faculty there should there will be
office hours some of those office hours
not all of them but some of those office
hours will be offered uh uh through
online through Zoom there are usually
um some kind of student form in addition
to that we have a slack channel that is
just for our students it's it's not a
place to ask course specific questions
but it's a place to ask logistical
questions
um You Follow The Graduate you know you
follow the the academic calendar again
10 weeks
um
and uh you know I see we have a we have
a typo I just see the price for the
graduate program should be the four
money signs for the professional program
should be two so the AI graduate program
is more expensive we got a really a lot
of great questions about you know if
there are any kind of fellowships or
scholarships that are offered
unfortunately there are not um in
general actually Stanford does not
provide those even for Master's programs
so um you know a lot of our students who
are taking either of these are being
reimbursed by their organizations that's
a common way that people fund it but
unfortunately there are not um
Fellowship programs for either of these
the professional programs are based on
that content right so usually they're
taking recorded lectures from one of the
more recent offerings of the of The
Graduate course and again The Graduate
lectures are the the lectures are being
recorded that you know you you'll see
them an hour after half an hour after
they've they've been given the
professional program is reusing the
lecture content in the syllabi from the
some of the graduate courses it has been
modified slightly to make it little bit
more manageable for for working
professionals though both are directed
at working professionals so usually it's
about 10 to 15 hours a week try to
maintain all the rigor of of the
graduate programs but maybe making one
module uh optional or something like
that to give you more time and in order
to work through the other stuff you do
not earn academic credit you'll earn a
professional certificate or continuing
education units and there is support
with industry experience course
facilitators are usually people who have
successfully completed The Graduate
course and probably also the
professional course and are very
familiar with the material and they they
support you through slack they support
you through email and then in addition
there's an online community of peers
there's a slack Channel again for those
courses and sort of allows you to
network into to ask questions and to
problem solve as you work through the
material they're very similar I would
say the other thing to note that is
maybe worth with mentioning here is the
graduate program as I said the the the
material and the delivery is it's going
to change every single time it's offered
because the new faculty or different
faculty are teaching it or the same
faculty updates the course the
professional program across all courses
will have a much more consistent
interface they'll have a much more
consistent experience because
we've been able to to sort of adjust it
a little bit so you'll you'll you know
once you start taking one AI
professional course you'll have a very
similar experience across others in
terms of the the interface and the
experience the graduate program there
can be a lot more variety in between
individual courses because a lot of the
details are up to the teaching team
um that's here there are a lot of other
really good questions that I try to uh
I tried to adjust some of them there
uh let me just one question that keeps
coming up for kind of the AI
professional program since we are doing
a little bit more work on the videos
like editing segmenting and you know we
need to kind of wait for the graduate
course to happen before we are able to
make updates if our courses are kind of
up to date because they are not
delivered live you're joining the
platform and they are definitely are we
always work with faculty on double
checking what's changed what we might
need to change uh especially I saw a
number of questions coming about xcs224
and an LP with deep learning and xcs224u
nlu because with the recent developments
with all things GPT uh we we always make
sure that the content is up to date I
just wanted to mention that
and one other uh thing to mention as
well we we uh a lot of questions about
going between the programs so there are
two separate applications uh but for the
professional program uh you can take a
graduate course and have it count
towards your your professional
certificate so for instance if you
wanted to take uh if you wanted to take
the computer vision course and it were
not it's not part of the AI professional
program you can take two course in the
professional program then take the one
graduate course and you know assuming
you're you're accepted into it and then
you would you could earn the
professional certificate you can't count
toward professional courses towards the
AI graduate program
um there was a good question about
whether if you like say completed CS so
this is confusing xcs229 which is the
professional version of machine learning
if that would count as a prerequisite
for the uh for the a graduate course
that asks for cs229
um I don't have a definitive answer now
we've been in conversation about
allowing that making that an option so
that you could take the prerequisite as
a as in the professional program and
then go into the graduate program and
take more advanced courses so I don't
have a definitive answer but we hope to
be working towards that I did we also
got some good questions about if you
were going to take either of these
courses where you do some of the
refresher um refresher material I would
say um we have a link of resources that
we we provide if you go to The Graduate
Pro certificate page and you click on
um the I think it's a course
materials I forget what we say maybe the
planning document that the certificate
planning document at the end of that we
list some materials that you can use uh
to to refresh your memory we do offer
through the the credit bearing program
so we do offer credit bearing programs
that meet a lot of the prerequisites so
you could take for instance
um you know as part of the the computer
science master's degree at Stanford
they're kind of the core courses which
include
um things like probability for computer
science
um discrete math which is uh you know
and and algorithms so you could take
some of those courses as graduate
courses for graduate credit to meet some
of those prerequisites or to get up to
speed if you're not up to speed on those
topics
um we do also offer math 51 which is
basically multi-variable calculus the
melting variable calculus and linear
algebra that you need in order to take
machine learning classes but we also
point you to free resources if you say
already met those prerequisites you just
need to refresh them there are a ton of
materials online that can help you do
that we also there are some lectures
that we have published on our YouTube
channel on on linear algebra and
introduction to machine learning on a
lot of these courses that allow you to
refresh refresh your memory most of
these Pro courses themselves will also
have
optional Refreshers on probability
theory on linear algebra on calculus on
those kinds of things because you know
all students will need to be up to speed
and it's not just uh online students who
need that refresher so again I recommend
going to The Graduate certificate page
clicking on the course plan the link at
the top on the course planning document
downloading that at the end you'll see
some some links to resources
um I think the professional program also
can provide some links uh there and so
yeah it's a great question Petra are
there other questions I I see we're at
we're Beyond time which is great there
have been a lot of good questions
um but are there any others you want to
address
um um I think just like I understand
like again like there's so many
questions and we'd really appreciate it
if we couldn't get to yours uh I also
posted the email address within the Q a
box and hopefully you also have the
access to the the kind of request the
email scpd AI uh Team so please don't
hesitate to reach out afterwards also
you know like there's you know I see the
questions coming up so I'm sure that
you're curious about
um about your question
I I think that that said parks there
wait so about some like we are trying to
answer them as we as we go uh so yeah
online our last slide is the question so
I I'll leave actually the the uh the I
think this summary is great
um so really appreciate everyone for
joining us today I know that was a ton
of information
um and we I know even when we answer
those questions sometimes there's so
much information it's hard to process at
all again I encourage you going to the
Stanford online website looking at those
programs
um is Petra said a lot of this stuff is
online and available for free as well so
let's say you wanted to you know think
about Stanford's machine learning
graduate course or even the professional
course well we have lecture videos from
2018 I think from the summer I think we
have three three years of lecture videos
there available online on our YouTube
channel so you can go watch the lectures
online see what those lectures will look
like see what the quality of the lecture
recordings are and then I would search
just Google search cs229 Stanford and
it'll likely pull up the most recent
offering of that course you look at the
syllabus and you can go through and say
you know what are the problems sometimes
they just have everything there they
have the problem sets they have you know
they have uh you know what the
assignment so you can get a good sense
of what the rigor of and the topics of
these classes are just by you know
spending 10 15 minutes searching on our
YouTube channel or searching on the um
or searching on the uh you know on on
their on their syllabus on their course
websites it's a really great place to
start and for many people also as Petra
said that's the better option you know
you you already have extensive
experience
um you just want to refresh it you can
go through that material as well um what
you're paying for here are the credits
and you're paying for the support that
it comes with taking it from a group of
peers and having professionals whether
those are Master students and PhD
students and faculty who are supporting
you or the experienced industry uh
facilitators so it's a lot to think
about we really appreciate you joining
us here again please don't hesitate to
email us with other questions and we
hope you have a great great rest of your
week
thanks everyone thank you so much thank
you